pourquoi
un beau design il est intra auriculaires
et en même temps son véhicule ce qui
permet d'abord la fonctionnalité en même
temps des écouteurs et du casque la
gombe particularité également ses qui
fait des tests auditifs via une
application à chaque utilisateur pouvoir
définir la qualité de son qui lui
corresponde parce que voilà comme de
notre façon totalement une façon de
relation différente de chaque personne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aucun fichier des landes à six-fours
nous 64 c'est quand même conséquent et
en fait il est doté d'une connexion 4g
illimité inclus pendant deux ans qui
vous permet de pouvoir en parlant
simplement d'avoir la traduction orale
et écrite de ce que vous dites via
l'appareil
bonjour comment allez vous il est
traduit à l'oral et à l'écrit
il ya le créole via le zulu ii dans le
tchèque le vietnamien les japonais tout
ce qu'il faut ça permet notamment de
pouvoir jouer à n'importe quel endroit
mais bon je vais sans déranger en
mettant simplement des écouteurs ou un
casque est également de pouvoir
apprendre à jouer quand on n'a pas les
moyens de se faire une batterie parce
que c'était à moindre coût
la technologie est très simple à
utiliser et à prendre en main donc ce
sont des simples capteur d'inclinaison
quévy kiwanja la tablette couleur
définissez des ongles disons que quand
vous tapez dans cette direction vous
tapez une partie de la batterie
[Musique]